[Music]
all right I want to get down to all the
things we should be eating we talked
about green leafy things yeah but
there's a lot more to it than that
that's what a lot of this is about so
let's get to it if you want to someone's
watching this right now yeah maybe
they're eating poorly maybe they're
eating okay maybe they think they're
doing a pretty good job but they want to
just kind of reset yeah take them from
beet one yeah so I mean I think the
first thing that people should do is
really cut out the processed foods which
is harder than it seems you know and and
I definitely my heart goes out to people
that feel like they can't give up the
junk food because again you know these
foods are not designed to be consumed in
moderation the advice to eat everything
in moderation is horrible in the modern
world in the modern supermarket
literally our our supermarket aisles are
lined with foods that are designed by
scientists that are paid a lot more than
you and I to create insatiable
overconsumption and addiction yeah wait
let's let's focus on that because it
sounds like it's not true but it's
actually true like they actually have
people working on isn't this what they
did with Doritos originally I think I
think that they mean that Cool Ranch
flavor
I usually just - I literally used to
just lick those chips you don't want to
eat your fingers yeah yeah yeah so there
are literally scientists working for
these companies making you want more and
more and more of this absolutely these
foods you know net which now make up
again 60% of the calories consumed in
the u.s. are designed to screw up your
brain and usually what happens is the
scientists will combine some parts sugar
wheat usually with fat and salt and it
creates this this unique mixture of
delectable you know mouthfeel as well as
just you know the the the exact
sensation that we've evolved basically
to seek out more of it just sets off
dopamine fireworks in our brains is that
actually the same thing that happens to
your brain when you do drugs and then
you need more drugs I mean is it really
the same chemical reactions that are
happening yeah absolutely if not worse I
mean they've done Studies on on
rats for example which are all it'd
basically in rats provide a really great
look into the behavior that certain
foods drive because you know they've got
no super-ego to steer them from what it
is that they really want to do they're
all it so they've shown that rats
actually prefer sugar to cocaine which
is funny because rats really like
cocaine yeah hi
rats really like cocaine they really
like cocaine yeah but um no I mean we
tend to think you know of ourselves as
having had like a moral failure right
like when we go through a whole bag of
chips or like eat the whole pint of ice
cream but again like these foods are not
designed to be consumed in moderation
they're designed literally to have you
finish that whole pint or that whole bag
and then go back as a repeat customer
yeah I always think the branding of it
is so funny to like you see all these
things like guilt-free chips or don't
feel bad about how fat you are it's for
any of this stuff and it's like it's all
this weird psychological play to get you
to keep eating ah yes no once you pop
you can't stop it's like a truism with
scientific backing yeah at this point
all right so the the reset person that's
watching this right now that's gonna
start doing some yeah okay get the
processed stuff out and that includes
like that's pretty much all the stuff
that you see in the frozen section yeah
like like all of that frozen breakfast
stuff and all those sandwiches and all
definitely and actually you know a
really good recommendation for people
that are really trying to make this
change is to first actually which is
kind of counterintuitive but to work on
your sleep sleep I like to say allows a
person getting good quality adequate
sleep gives a person the hormonal
fortitude to make those dietary changes
so when you you know when you're under
slept actually a study was just put out
showing the people tend to over consume
and eat excess calories predominantly
from these exact kinds of foods so yeah
optimising sleep and then what do they
say on sleep like is it eight hours
really is that what they want for like
the average yeah eight hours is a good
amount and then it's that's also roughly
the amount of sleep that you need to
maximize growth hormone which is an
important hormone in the body for
preserving lean mass but yeah I mean in
quality sleep as well so I mean not just
getting those eight hours but making
sure that those eight hours are really
you know super high quality
and we can get into ways of optimizing
sleep I guess one of them one of the
best ways that I like to optimize my
sleep and I find it to be very effective
is to limit my exposure to screens at
night because what time do you shut down
yeah I mean I shut down I try to shut
down two to three hours before bed or if
I if I'm not shutting down and I have to
work up until the point of which you
know I go to bed I mean let's face it
living in the real world you know
sometimes we have to respond to an
urgent email I use blue light blocking
glasses mm-hmm
which I'm a big fan of actually and
there's good research on amber colored
glasses and their ability to sort of
mitigate some of the loss of melatonin
do you know is that the same effect that
the iPhone has now with their night
thing is that that same thing I'm not
sure that I'm filtering yeah
yeah I'm not sure if it's comparable
actually I mean I'd feel it certainly
feels way better to my eyes when night
shift is on but yeah I mean I noticed
that when I so in my house in New York
I've got it's my brother's I live with
my brother he has a massive TV it's like
85 inches or just one of the biggest
monsters at television I've ever seen in
my life and you know he likes to watch
movies up until the point at which he
goes to bed and that's not my preference
but I do that with him sometimes and
I'll watch like a movie up until like
midnight or something and I notice that
when I have that amount of light pouring
into my face when I go to bed right
after that I'll oftentimes actually wake
up feeling hungover even though I've
never I've had the eight hours of sleep
and I hadn't had any alcohol
I just feel under slept and not
rejuvenated whereas when I wear the blue
light blogging glasses and I have no you
know I'm not uh you know formally
affiliated with any of these companies I
don't manufacture them in any sense but
uh but I do find that they work I wait I
wake up feeling a lot more refreshed
when I hear them I well I think that the
digital piece of this is so interesting
as I talk about it with almost every
guest like just the frustration with
social media and not putting this stuff
down in digital addiction and and all of
this and it's like one of the things
that I've tried to do is I never bring
my phone into my room anymore
badge tomorrow I just stopped doing it
because I realized wow right before I go
to bed I'm looking at my phone and then
literally the first thing I do when I
wake up yeah before I brush my teeth
before I go to the bathroom is I'm
suddenly looking at my phone again like
even if it's all wonderful news it's
probably not and it's usually not yeah
but even if it was it's probably not a
great way to start saying so that and
I've really really been trying to do no
technology on the weekends and I think
and I think that that's really helped so
is there some sort of connection between
all of that and and like just the
digital monster that's affecting iodine
- yeah I mean there's no you're just
like well yeah I mean I think from a
mood standpoint for sure I mean like you
know our stress response evolved at a
time when things that were stressful to
us required our immediate attention
right so cycle there yeah like a bear in
your face yeah like this like protracted
long-term psychological stress though
that so many of us have you know so
commonly today is a fairly new invention
in on the evolutionary timescale and the
media for example knows this and like an
app developer app developers know this
that's why I like you turn on any you
know news station local news especially
they abide by the if it bleeds it leads
mentality put the most anxiety inducing
segment up front or tease at it at least
so that it causes an expression of or an
upregulation of norepinephrine in the
brain which is basically the brain's
focus and attention neurotransmitter
associated with stress and that's
something that you know it makes you
more alert makes you feel more awake and
so when you read you know doom and gloom
news on your on your smartphone you're
basically having the same exact stress
response yeah it's funny how when you
step away from it a little bit to how
silly it almost seems so like when I get
away on the weekend and then I'm back on
Monday if I look back at anything that
might have happened and I see all these
people find I'm like wow you all spent
your weekend just fighting about this
stuff it's one thing that we're doing it
on the weekdays and maybe we can all
manage that myself included maybe we can
all manage that a little differently
nope that endless sort of you know way
out thing it's it's a lot it also yeah I
mean I'm not as familiar with the there
was this there was a study that came out
showing that just
having your smartphone around you is
exhausting from a cognitive standpoint
you know just sort of having it around
and sort of feeling that pull we get
addicted to it I mean it sort of you
know hijacks our dopamine systems as
well you know being addicted to social
media that's a real thing yeah it's
interesting to me though because people
watch this show and we know what our
watch times are and they're off the
charts for for YouTube which usually has
like a seven second watch time or
something and that shows to me that
people want long-form they actually want
something that isn't so insulting to
their senses to their brain now
ironically many people are watching this
right now or listening on their phones
but a lot of people listen on their
phones while they're doing exercise or
while their computer you're saying but I
do sense that people want something else
so it's like the news is giving us the
local news as you're saying they're
giving us something we don't want
because they know it'll keep us there
but food companies are giving us
something that's not good for us because
they know it'll keep us there we now
know Tristan Harris who I've had on
talked about how the tech companies and
you just alluded to this are giving us
things that they know are bad first so
it really is your job yeah it's like a
full-time job now as a human to be like
I'm gonna do the things that actually
argued for me not the things you keep
feeding well exactly and you know that's
why I think it's such a shame because we
each are heir to this amazing gift right
the human brain yet the modern world is
like The Hunger Games right like
attacking it from every which way and we
are not equipped with the tools to
understand you know what to do to sort
of fix that situation yeah and so yeah I
mean I definitely recommend people
taking a break you know from social
media from news the 24-hour news cycle I
think is just not healthy and then also
certainly food you know I think food is
a major part of it lifestyle you know
one of the things that I talked about in
the book we go into depth is the fact
that you know not only are we more
sedentary than we've ever been not
getting enough exercise but you know
there's a there was another form of
exercise that we all had for the
majority of our evolution and that is
thermal exercise you know today we live
in a time where you know there's chronic
climate control you know and that's
something that seems to be to the
detriment of our metabolisms
so I talked about how you can use you
know cold showers to enhance vigilance
which is one of the few things that you
can do that you actually feel a shift in
your consciousness are you big on that
people there are these people that like
jump from like the hot tub to a freezing
cold I do that yeah you know wait maybe
it was you that I thought you were you
took a picture like in a pool or
something yeah yeah it must've been you
I think the first time I saw it so what
is that so you jump in from hot water to
cold water in your system is just like
constantly rebooting yeah well it's
called contrast therapy so basically you
know and your and a lot of the
mechanisms are sort of conserved between
the two activities so you know when you
go into a cold when you go into like a
sauna for example you're activating
something called heat shock proteins
which are there to sort of guard the
proteins in your body against
disfigurement which is really important
because a lot of the diseases that we're
talking about Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease are associated with
misfolded proteins so anytime we can
sort of activate these heat shock
proteins seems to be helpful
they're also activated when you expose
yourself to cold air yeah there's really
good there's really good research a lot
of people now are practicing cryotherapy
as a means of enhancing you know
vigilance reducing inflammation boosting
metabolism increasing the proliferation
of brown fat we all have a kind of fad
in us that it wasn't thought that adults
carried it with them past you know
childhood or infancy but now we know
that we actually have this sort of fad
it's actually a good fat a fad that we
want more of because it's metabolically
active and it burns calories so by going
into cold I mean keeping ourselves
exposed too you know it intermittent
cooler temperatures we actually
encourage the proliferation of this hat
which is really cool so I thought by
moving to LA and being an 80-degree so
every day was good that was a good thing
I guess it's good for my vitamin D but
that's not good for some of this other
stuff yeah yes I so I think getting back
to that you know having a little bit
more thermal stress in our lives is
important they've done really good
research on people with type 2 diabetes
and have found that you know even mild
cold below you know or higher I should
say than then what would be like a
freezing temperature does improve
insulin sensitivity which is sort of the
hallmark of metabolic
health which is really interesting it's
a way to improve your health without
even doing anything I mean you basically
just turn the dial on your air
conditioner down a little bit more yeah
all right so now let's circle back okay
okay this person starts that word this
imaginary person that we're talking
about that's watching right now I'm
going all right I'm going to incorporate
some of that stuff yes they're gonna get
the the Eggos leg oh my they're gonna
get that out of the way processed food
in the morning right what are they
replacing that with for breakfast yeah
so I mean start this day okay let's
start the day well first of all there is
no biological need for breakfast so
let's just get you know get that out of
the picture but I thought breakfast was
the most important meal of the day the
meal that you break your fast with is
important but there's no biological need
to eat as soon as you wake up so whether
you push that first meal an hour after
you wake up or two hours after you wake
up you should be able to do that I mean
breakfast is a fairly new construct you
know in the evolutionary sense and also
when you wake up first thing in the
morning your body has a really unique
hormonal milieu where it wants to burn
fat you know cortisol is at its highest
it Peaks immediately after you wake up
and cortisol is sort of like the body's
fat burning hormone it's the body's
chief catabolic hormone liberate stored
fatty acids sugars proteins and sort of
throw breakfast into that equation
especially in the most commonly the most
commonly consumed form of it which is
you know as you said like a Lego an eggo
waffle yeah no offense there go and
Doritos before yeah where does naming
some things here yeah yeah what for the
person though that wants to have you
know something in the morning fat and
fiber and protein so you know eggs are a
perfect food to eat first thing in the
morning a scramble for example with some
spinach kale and some extra virgin olive
oil or you can use a little bit of
coconut oil that's a you know great eat
an avocado oh those are two good oils
cuz every I feel like every year someone
says grapeseed oils good now I know you
I saw on your website get rid of the
great yellow carrot or something to do a
grapeseed oil okay no problem yes but
when you're cooking you so basically
you're saying coconut oil or coconut oil
is good yeah you can actually cook with
a extra-virgin olive oil it maintains
you know it doesn't oxidize the way
some of these awful grain and seed oils
will corn oil soybean oil canola oil
grape seed oil these are the worst yeah
that's basically like the smoke point
part right where it becomes actually
interestingly and this is a question I
get asked a lot smoke point and the
temperature at which an oil oxidizes
there there's no relationship so smoke
point is something that's like a
culinary concern more than anything else
and in fact these oils like canola oil
corn oil soybean oil are so heavily
processed in order for them to have a
high smoke point but actually they
become rancid at much lower temperatures
whereas you take a you know like a fat
like butter butter will start to smoke
pretty early on but it's not because the
fat oxidizing is because of the proteins
and the KCM you know the trace lactose
encasing and found in butter but that
actually has no bearing on whether or
not it's good or bad for you
so basically though if you were making
you know an egg yeah you some use some
kale and spinach you're talking about
olive oil you're talking about coconut
oil use some water or butter yeah yeah
exactly yeah because you know the more
saturated an oil is the more chemically
stable it's gonna be at higher
temperatures so higher heat cooking you
want to use coconut oil butter ghee lard
tallow things like that
my coffee right now it's got ghee and
MCT oil and and collagen in it it
doesn't really taste like coffee anymore
but it's not bad collagen is awesome I
did a great you know article deep dive
into the health benefits of collagen on
my website and MCT oil is great I don't
you know I don't really see people that
have no idea MCT oil it's it's like an
extract of coconut oil yes yeah so MCT
oil is digested differently than other
fats it basically goes straight to the
liver and it becomes converted to
ketones which are a sort of alternate
fuel that the brain will readily use
when they're available and there's some
really interesting research on MCT as a
potential intervention for patients with
Alzheimer's disease it might
theoretically help people sort of wean
themselves off of carbs by sort of
supplementing brain energy and yeah it
could also you know I think just in
terms of making you feel like you've had
something first thing in the morning
slowing the release of caffeine and
your bloodstream no that's great but
again you want to be careful with the
added fats because they're very they're
not nutrient dense and if you're trying
to lose weight there's no need to add a
ton of oils to your diet I know that's
the irony of where I'm at with this
thing not to make this about but like I
somehow actually have lost a couple
pounds while doing this very high-fat
thing but I hear what you're saying yeah
I actually probably could cut down on
that and then my body will go to the
actual instead of the fat of putting in
there and I don't break it to you but
the weight that you lost could be water
at the same time so yeah adding adding
you know oils to the dog okay so you
have the you have basically an omelet
something to that effect in the morning
yeah with some greens in there or yogurt
full fat yogurt grass-fed yogurt you
know that's something that I think is
great can we explain why grass-fed is so
important because I feel like there's a
certain set of people that are always
kind of like you know you go to get
grass out you grass bed like that
doesn't do anything it's no well it
dictates the healthiness of the fat you
know so if you're talking about like
grass-fed whey protein for example makes
much less of a difference because whey
protein is just pure protein but if
you're talking about you know a piece of
red meat or something grass-fed red meat
compared to grain fed red meat it's a
different animal even though it's a same
animal it's basically I mean one in
grass-fed red meat you have a ratio of
omega-6 fats to omega-3 fats that
basically mirrors that of the human
brain you've got a lot more carotenoids
which are basically these fat soluble
antioxidant compounds that have been
shown to boost processing speed in the
brain which is really important cows
that eat grass grass contains these
carotenoids carotenoids which are fat
soluble they become embedded in the fat
of the cow and so when you eat a piece
of steak from a cow that's been
grass-fed you're eating those
carotenoids along with fat that helps
you absorb it because they need fat to
be absorbed so I mean it's a really
healthy food when you you know when
we're talking about grass-fed meat and
then in terms of yogurt grass-fed yogurt
you know full fat can have you know a
few omega-3s it's not a major source but
it's got CLA vitamin k2 much higher in
grass-fed in the fat of grass-fed full
fat yogurt
you know conventional yogurt I feel like
lunch is the hard one for a lot of
people computer at work a lot of people
are barely leaving their desks at work
even for me you know working from home
even but I'm so busy during the day it's
like hi we just got to grab something or
get Chipotle or whatever it is what can
you do in the midday you can have a
relatively healthy meal at Chipotle
I mean Chipotle still you know I think
in all of their options has uses you
know one of those oils you know green
and you know probably canola oil I'm not
I'm not sure which but yeah I mean you
can get guacamole there which is
certainly very healthy avocado is
incredible for you it's again packed
with carotenoids on avocado has twice
the potassium of a banana which is
amazing people think about potassium
they only think about bananas very low
carb food you can get some protein and
then the salsa I think is fine you know
so you can and the bell peppers are
great but generally like what I tell
people for lunch is it's a great
opportunity during the day to eat a
salad I think people should be eating a
large salad every single day again the
research is pretty compelling and you
know mechanistically it makes sense that
dark leafy greens would be really good
for a person they're the most nutrient
dense foods there are meaning there's
tons of nutrients for very few calories
they're packed with dietary fiber which
you know will not only help fill you up
but it feeds the microorganisms that
live in your large intestine this is
called the microbiome which is a really
exciting focus now in research and you
want to make that salad fatty and I
don't mean by putting you know tortilla
strips and ranch dressing and cheese on
it or even commercial salad dressings
you really want to avoid those but
there's no better vehicle for extra
virgin olive oil than a salad an extra
virgin olive oil going back to the
Mediterranean dietary pattern it's a
hallmark and they've done research
you know randomized control trials where
they look specifically at extra-virgin
olive oil one of the you know the sort
of best studies to look at was done out
of Barcelona Spain called the pretty med
study where they gave subjects a leader
of extra-virgin olive oil extra virgin
olive oil to consume per week and they
found that you know at the end of I
think
the trial went on for six years they had
improved cognitive function they had
improved risk factors for cardiovascular
disease and they even lost weight so by
adding more fat to their diet they ended
up losing weight although it was
extra-virgin olive oil it wasn't butter
right okay so now we've had the omelet
started the bay we've had a big green
leafy salad for lunch maybe some protein
in there
yeah what's happening for dinner yeah so
for dinner I'm a big fan of grass-fed
you know red meat I think that's one of
the more controversial tips that I give
people because meat you know has sort of
been in the dog house for so long but I
thought one day a week a red meat no I
mean the thing is I don't there's no you
know there was a really great study
performed by a Charlotte Newman at UCLA
where they gave it was again a
randomized control trial they gave
children in Kenya
this traditional porridge dish made of
beans and green beans and things like
that you know what a control group had
just the sort of vegetarian version and
they gave a group the version with dairy
and they gave a group a version with
meat and they found that the kids that
were given the version with supplemented
meat added meat actually at the end of
the trial had improved cognitive
function and signs of mental health so
there's other research actually from
that iSight ingenious foods from
Australia Deakin University where they
found that women who didn't consume the
nationally recommended 3 to 4 servings
of red meat per week actually had twice
the risk for depression or an anxiety or
a mood disorder and so you know I think
it's there's a what's called like a
u-shaped curve I think definitely some
red meat is better than none
but eating too much isn't great either
you definitely want to have a diet
that's rich in vegetables dark leafy
greens kale spinach things like that but
in that context I think that eating
properly raised meat is definitely
definitely healthy fatty fish for dinner
would be another another option fish is
packed with micronutrients that the
brain needs to create new cells which we
now know the adult brain can do up until
death and yeah I mean you know there's
there's a lot of options I think you
know when you look at a plate you want
to have half of it vegetables and half
of it meat
I don't think eating one of the I think
incorrect interpretations of the Paleo
diet is that it's meant to be a really
high meat diet I think that ignores a
lot of the research now again
surrounding the microbiome which is this
area that's very new but you know we
want to get a good you know amount of
dietary fiber micronutrients which the
brain needs and there's no better way to
do that than with than with veggies so
how often do you cheat on this stuff
because I'm guessing a certain amount of
people are watching this going alright
this is what this guy does for a living
yeah he's writing books about it you
know I mean he has the the time to
prepare meals the way he wants etcetera
etcetera how often do you go off the
deep end and you know a couple times a
year but you know I think I think God
had the cravings for that's no I don't
scream I don't to be totally honest and
I I've always had a huge sweet tooth but
I yeah I don't really once I made the
transition to a lower carb diet I don't
have those cravings in fact I can
comfortably go hours without eating I
think that's a really good subjective
sign of metabolic resilience what about
alcohol where does that fit in since I
know you mentioned the one glass of wine
for a woman what are they why don't I
have to do once to four men per day yeah
is that basically aligned with what your
yeah I mean there's you know some
researchers recommend you know consuming
red wine it's part of this sort of mind
diet which is a dietary sort of pattern
that was created at Rush University but
I don't you know I think I think it's
hard to study alcohol because on the one
hand it's such a powerful social
lubricant and feeling connected to one
another and of course you know as a
solvent for stress I think it's really
powerful and that's not to be discounted
you know we live stressful lives and
there's sort of no way around that for
for many people but Ethan all is a
neurotoxin and I think if you're if you
have a way of dealing with stress and
feeling connected with you know with one
another without it I think you're
probably better off doing that but I do
give some tips in the book about how to
make consuming alcohol as healthy and
experiences as possible you want to
avoid sugary mixers I think beer is you
know one of the least healthiest
alcohols that you can consume you always
want to follow the one-for-one rule you
know chase every drink with a glass of
water and also you know alcohol is a
diuretic and when you pee a lot you
excrete sodium and so by replenishing
those electrolytes you know while you're
drinking I think that's really important
so sprinkle a little a little bit of
salt in your water for example could be
one way to do that right people don't
realize that like you don't need down a
Gatorade just because you lost a couple
electrolytes literally just a little
salt in your water a little bit of salt
yeah I actually became have become
really interested in salt I yeah I carry
a little vial of salt in my gym bag now
and after a good sauna session or
workout I sprinkle a little bit in my
mouth yeah yeah Wow
yeah cuz you're you lose you lose great
people they're not gonna be happy
they're not gonna be happy about that
you lose especially when you're on a
low-carb diet when you drop the carbs
your insulin comes down and insulin
basically tells the kidneys to hold on
to sodium you know unnaturally so for
people that are on a really high carb
diet which most most Americans are
consuming 300 grams of carbs a day with
insulin levels constantly elevated
they're holding on to excess sodium so
the recommendation to watch your sodium
intake in that sort of context makes a
lot of sense but if you're eating a low
carb diet as you should focused on you
know whole foods that are not packed
with starch you really need to be
mindful of not only your sodium intake
because again sodium's sodium is a
nutrient it's not this poison that you
know you would think it was looking at
the labels of you know processed foods
that are low in sodium and that's
somehow supposed to make it okay that
you're eating you know tons of sugar and
and and processed wheat yeah so you need
to really be mindful that and then you
do other things in your lifestyle that
that accelerate the the spilling of
sodium so like exercise drinking coffee
which causes you to pee out a lot of
sodium I did a great interview with a
researcher who focuses on this topic and
yeah it's a it's an area of interest for
me and definitely when I when I wake up
in the morning if I'm doing like
one of my really you know particularly
low-carb phases I'll sprinkle you know a
little bit of salt in my water and it
makes me feel it gives me like a boost
of energy like yeah interesting
all right so let's go full circle here
so basically about six years ago that's
when this all started and yeah and your
mom was diagnosed he obviously changed
her life afterwards changed your life
where's your mom at now and and how have
the things everything we've talked about
in this last hour how have you been able
to incorporate them into her life and
and see see some changes I mean you know
I've I've tried especially when I moved
from LA back to New York I I really
tried to take a you know super hands-on
approach for as long as I could with my
mom to change her diet and certainly
some some aspects of her diet has
changed but you know dementia is a
horrible disease and it makes it really
hard on both the patient and the
caregiver to to adhere to strict dietary
interventions you know there was a study
that I was that I dove into recently
where they put people with Alzheimer's
disease both mild to moderate
Alzheimer's disease on a ketogenic diet
and they found that one of the major
limitations of the study is that
adherence is so high - you know - these
diets and it's a major stress on the
caregiver I'm not my mom's caregiver but
at a certain point I had to kind of
teach and step back you know so that you
know if I am around my mom she's craving
something that you know isn't max
approved it doesn't affect my
relationship with her because first and
foremost I love my mom and you know I
don't want to do anything to compromise
the relationship or her quality of life
so I wonder is there any work done that
people with dementia I can sort of
remember this from my grandmother who
had dementia and I spent a lot of time
with her her last few years that she was
an incredible cook used to cook all
sorts of exotic things but in her later
years as the dementia kicked in she
really only wanted the same few things
is that do you think somehow connected
to like there's just certain things
maybe that are still in the memory like
sorry like she really suddenly wanted
chicken soup all the time but I don't
remember really her having chicken soup
for many years before that she would
cook these crazy meals
yeah I mean the only shift in food
preference that I'm familiar with is a
shift towards sweeter foods which occurs
and it's thought that that happens
because a brain with Alzheimer's disease
is essentially being starved of its you
know one of its primary energy
substrates which is glucose so there's
this notion that Alzheimer's disease is
a form of diabetes of the brain it's
essentially become unable to properly
process glucose that's where ketogenic
interventions have shown a lot of
promise and it's thought that that might
be really helpful for a patient with
Alzheimer's disease and one of the
things that that sort of strengthens
that that notion is that they that
people you know that that perhaps never
expressed a preference for sweet foods
or had a sweet tooth begin to crave
sugar and it's thought that that's sort
of the brain crying out for sugar as a
means of creating energy but the irony
is that those are the exact kinds of
foods that drive inflammation and you
know insulin resistance in the body and
that are so detrimental to the brain to
begin with yeah there's really there's
really interesting you know and
ketogenic diets are I think they've
become a little buzzed were they these
days and popular but there's a lot of
good research on them they're hard to
study there's not a lot of money to go
around to to really to study them but
there's good evidence that actually one
of my friends published a study on
patients with mild cognitive impairment
we're putting patients with with mild
cognitive impairment on a ketogenic diet
seem to improve cognitive function and
then just recently that was extended to
patients with Alzheimer's disease which
we were all waiting for we're all
waiting for a ketogenic trial to be
performed on patients with diagnosed
Alzheimer's disease and it seemed that
for the patients that were able to
adhere to it there was a significant
improvement in their cognitive function
when they were on that diet and they
went back to you know their baseline
level of cognitive function after the
trial ended which really you know
strengthens the notion that ketones were
helping the brain sort of as an
energetic life raft it seems that the
main takeaway here is do some of the
preventional work completely again you
know Al's high murmurs disease begins in
the brain 30 to 40 years before the
first symptoms
before the first symptom and there's
even some data suggesting that this
could be a lifelong thing for people
with certain genes that put them at
higher risk for Alzheimer's disease like
the apoe4 allele which 1 in 4 people
carry yeah
well it's a pleasure to see you you've
become a master of your craft and I
think it maybe has a little something to
do with what you're eating because
you're pulling information pretty
quickly so I think you've the proof is
in the gluten free pudding or something
like that
all right genius foods comes out March
20th yes yes see I memorized that that
was pretty impressive and bread had your
documentary that's in the works right
now that's in the works that will come
out at some point this year people can
check out a kickstarter teaser at
breadhead movie calm yeah we'll link to
that right down below and genius foods
is is up for pre-order now I mean it's
it's gonna be everywhere books are sold
so thank you all right well it's been a
pleasure I think doing this with you
while I'm in the midst of this diet
you've given me some ways that maybe I
can change it a little less fat and well
we'll revisit this privately in a couple
of months and then and then we'll do
this again for sure awesome things all
right well for more on Macs follow him
on the Twitter it's max Lucca be or lu g
AV e re
[Music]
you
[Music]